- [Narrator] Americans are
heading to the polls after weeks
of record setting early voting.
Key battleground states
could decide who wins
the presidential race between
President Donald Trump
and former Vice President Joe Biden.
And some states are just now beginning
to count a flood of mail-in ballots,
meaning election results could
take days to be announced.
- We will make America great again.
Thank you Pennsylvania.
(crowd cheering)
Thank you, Pennsylvania.
- I'm running as a proud Democrat
but I will govern as an American president
- [Narrator] After an
unprecedented campaign season,
election day 2020 has finally arrived
with both candidates
offering dueling visions
for the nation's future.
Trump has pledged to
be a political outsider
who will bring the economy back,
while Biden pitched himself as a president
who can unite a divided country.
Months of preparations
to hold a safe election
and tabulate early votes
will be put to the test,
capping a race that has
largely been defined
by the coronavirus pandemic.
Many States have already
seen historic levels
of early voting and more
than two thirds of responders
in the latest National
WSJ/NBC News poll said,
they plan to vote early
either by mail or in person
- You're too have a duty, a duty to vote.
- [Narrator] Polls
indicate that supporters
of Biden are more likely
to have voted early.
(crowd shouting)
While supporters of Trump are more likely
to vote in person on election day.
- Get your friends, get your
family, get your neighbors,
get your coworkers, get your boss,
grabbed him by the tie
say, "Let's go boss."
(crowd laughing)
And get out and vote.
- [Narrator] Turnout will
also impact other key races.
Republicans are defending
their senate majority
which is up for grabs
as 14 seats are now
considered competitive.
And Democrats are working to hold
and expand their majority in the house,
particularly in suburban districts.
(upbeat music)
And keep an eye on the battleground states
that could decide the presidential race.
- Hello, Wisconsin.
We're back.
We're back, we gotta win.
- Ohio, one more day.
- Well, hello Pennsylvania.
- What's up Miami.
- [Narrator] Key states to watch,
include the Western States
of Nevada and Arizona.
The Midwestern State of Iowa,
Southern States, Texas, Georgia,
Florida and North Carolina.
And perhaps most importantly,
the Great Lake States
of Wisconsin, Michigan,
Ohio and Pennsylvania.
That's where the candidates held most
of their events in the
final hours of the campaign.
- I've gotten to know
this state very well.
You know, you surprise,
you know you're the one
that put us over the top,
you know that, right?
Remember.
(crowd cheering)
- Pennsylvania, 2008 and 2012,
you placed your trust in Barack and me.
Now in 2020, I'm asking
for your trust again.
- [Narrator] Well, the most recent,
WSJ/NBC News national poll shows Joe Biden
with a 10 point lead.
The race could hinge on states
that President Trump flipped
by slim margins four years ago.
In 2016, Trump won Michigan
by less than 11,000 votes,
Wisconsin by less than 23,000 votes
and Pennsylvania by about 44,000 votes.
- Put you ballot right over here.
- [Narrator] And what about results?
Well, we may get early clues
about the race from Florida,
Ohio and North Carolina
where polls closed between
7 and 8:00 PM Eastern.
It could take days
to know the winner of
states like Pennsylvania,
Michigan and Wisconsin.
That's because laws in those states say,
election officials couldn't
count mail-in ballots ahead
of this week.
In some states ballots that
arrive after election day,
may also be counted as
long as they're postmarked
by November 3rd.
The late tallying rules
have both parties preparing
for legal battles.
- We should know the result of
the election on November 3rd,
the evening of November 3rd.
(crowd cheering)
That's the way it's been and
that's the way it should be.
What's going on in this country?
- I don't care how hard
Donald Trump tries.
There's nothing, let me say that again.
There's nothing that he
can do to stop the people
in this station from voting
in overwhelming numbers
and taking back this democracy.
(crowd cheering)